estas imágenes difundidas por la policía
israelí muestran cientos de fuegos
artificiales explotando mientras las
fuerzas entran en la mezquita al Axa de
Jerusalén en la madrugada del miércoles
las personas que se encontraban adentro
del lugar de culto afirman que fueron
agredidas físicamente por los agentes
israelíes
la policía israelí no se atacó allí
dentro todos los jóvenes que están
dentro están sufriendo y nadie les ayuda
qué esperan atacaron a todos los que
estaban dentro todas las ventanas de la
mezquita están rotas
[Aplausos]
la violencia se produce casi a mitad del
ramadán y cuando los judíos se preparan
para celebrar la Pascua judía la policía
israelí ha emitido un comunicado
tratando de justificar las acciones de
los oficiales esta noche mientras la
policía trabajaba para permitir que un
gran número de musulmanes celebraran el
mes del ramadán varios jóvenes forajidos
y agitadores enmascarados introdujeron
fuegos artificiales palos y piedras en
la mezquita tras largos e infructuosos
intentos de sacarlos mediante el diálogo
la policía se vio obligada a
desalojarlos para permitir que tuvieran
lugar las primeras oraciones del Alba y
evitar disturbios violentos el incidente
ha recibido la condena internacional
tanto de Egipto como de arradia Saudita
Esta última ha declarado que socava los
esfuerzos de paz en la región tras los
enfrentamientos se dispararon varios
cohetes desde el norte de la franja de
gaza hacia el territorio israelí el
grupo palestino jamás denunció lo que
calificó de Crimen Sin precedentes los
cohetes palestinos provocaron una rápida
respuesta aviones de combate israelíes
atacaron gaza a primera hora de la
mañana del miércoles según jamás los
ataques alcanzaron dos campos de
entrenamiento uno en la ciudad de gaza y
otro en un campo de refugiados